ILYA GRIGORIK: Hello everyone,
and welcome to our "Make the
Web Fast" series here on
Google Developers Live.
Today we'll be talking about
a very awesome tool called
mod_pagespeed, which
is a performance
JIT for your website.
So first off, my name
is Ilya Grigorik.
I work with the "Make
the Web Fast" team.
And with me today--
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Hi.
I'm Marinates And I work on
the mod_pagespeed team.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Awesome.
So Josh, I heard through the
rumor mill that there is an
upcoming 1.0 release
for mod_pagespeed.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's
correct.
The rumors are correct.
We are releasing mod_pagespeed
1.0 next week.
After two years of beta it's
ready for broader adoption.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Wow.
So true to Google philosophy of
keeping everything in beta,
that's two years and quite
a few users, I
think, as well, right?
So it'll be really interesting
to dive in and understand
what's happening underneath,
because I spent some time
looking at what you guys
have built, certainly
worked with the team.
And the first thing that
stands out to me--
I guess we have some slides
that I've prepared--
is that if you care about
performance, there's a lot of
stuff that you need
to care about.
In fact, my officemate, Steve
Souders, wrote a couple books
on the subject.
And there is stuff like image
compression, combining your
resources, and deferring
JavaScript, cache extensions.
Frankly, it's a full-time job to
keep up with all the things
that you need to do to keep
your website fast.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
We believe that if you're
building a website, you're
trying to convey information.
You're trying to sell a product,
gain acceptance of an
idea, communicate something.
You're not trying to hack your
website to make it faster.
So the less you have to focus
on that, the better.
Now, it is important that you
make websites fast because you
get more engagement,
happier users.
People will come back.
But you don't want to spend
all your time doing that.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
And that's actually a very good
point, very important
point, which is of course
we care about speed.
But speed in itself can be
almost a full-time job,
because even these best
practices change over time.
The browsers get smarter.
We get more video on the web,
more images on the web.
So these things shift, and you
need to keep up with it.
And not only that, but some
techniques, like let's say
spriting images together or
inlining resources on the
page, are actually pretty heavy
in terms of required
work, either for the design
team or for the dev team.
So it adds additional
complexity to
your development cycle.
So it's not all just easy
wins along the way.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: And the other
aspect is that sometimes it's
hard to draw a balance between
being able to keep your site
up to date and keeping
it cached.
For example, everybody knows who
works on web performance
that the more assets
on a website that
are cached, the better.
So if you go back to a typical
newspaper site every day to
see what the news is, you'll
typically wind up downloading
their JavaScript and their CSS,
which hasn't changed--
usually has not changed--
every day, because they
have to set a
fairly short cache lifetime.
I typically see a minute or an
hour at the most in order so
that they can push changes
out when they want to.
But they don't do
it every day.
They probably do it once
every few weeks.
And you want to be able to
change your website on the fly
and have that propagate quickly
to everybody, but also
have it so that when you don't
change it, it stays in
people's caches.
So this is a complicated and
messy thing to do manually.
It's a very easy thing
to automatically.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
And I think that is the core
insight behind mod_pagespeed,
which is to say, sure, you
can apply all these
optimizations yourself.
And in fact, you should know
them, because they should be
best practices on your team.
But we can, in fact, automate
some of this stuff.
And that's what mod_pagespeed
is all about.
That's why we say it's a
performance JIT, Just In Time
compiler, in your web server.
So maybe you can tell us a
little bit as to what that
actually means and how
you guys have gone
about doing this work.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Sure.
There are a number of approaches
to automated
website automation.
And our approach was to make
it really easy to adopt.
So half the websites around
the world are powered by
Apache web servers.
And so what we did was we
packaged our optimization
framework as an open-source
Apache module.
So you pretty much in three
commands can download our
package, install it, and restart
Apache, and your
website runs faster.
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's a pretty
compelling pitch.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: There's
then more you can do.
There's a core set of filters
that we believe is very safe,
will benefit websites a
lot and be very safe
to run on all websites.
And those come on when
you do that process.
But then there's more that you
can do if you're willing to
investigate and tune
it a little bit.
But the whole idea was out
of the box, really good
performance.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
And safe, right?
So your website shouldn't
be broken.
And I think we'll actually take
a look at kind of deep in
the guts of some of the filters
and how they work.
But before we even get there,
one of the things that I
wanted to highlight was that
I believe mod_pagespeed is
actually based on another
open-source project.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's right.
So the way that it is structured
is that we thought
Apache was a very good delivery
vehicle for our
technology.
But we know it's not the only
delivery vehicle for our
technology that can
ever exist.
So we layered this as an
optimization framework called
the PageSpeed Optimization
Libraries, which is not tied
to any particular server.
It's a plug-in architecture.
And we'll get into that more
a little bit later.
And then we packaged that with
a connection to Apache, an
Apache gasket, if you will, so
that it's just plug-and-play
and you don't have to modify
the structure.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So mod_pagespeed
is basically a
wrapper around PageSpeed
Optimization
Libraries for Apache.
But if I want to adopt it
to some other server--
maybe I've written one myself,
or I'm using some other
popular server--
I could actually still
reuse that same code.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yes.
And in fact, this is what we
have done with PageSpeed
service, so that we've now
deployed this on two very
different server stacks, one
based on Apache, one an
internal Google one.
But we can bring the same
technology in two very
different deployments.
And we are looking to expand
to any server that rises in
popularity as well.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
And PageSpeed Service is our
hosted version of this, which
is actually still in beta,
and we're still kind of
field-testing it with
other customers.
But it's actually running
on the same code
base, if you will.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yes.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Very cool.
So I think we covered
some of this.
We have a 1.0 coming.
We know that it's an
Apache module.
You guys have been working
on it for over two years.
And you actually mentioned some
of the core filters and
optional filters.
And it sounds like there's
quite a few.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
There's a wide variety.
There's a lot of ideas.
Web performance is a topic
that invites papers.
It invites conferences.
Many companies are founded
around this.
And there's lots of ideas that
are pouring into this.
But we try to take the ones that
are most effective, that
are incredibly robust and
predictable, and put them into
the core set so that the
out-of-the-box experience is
really good.
And then there are a lot of
other things that we are
working on, that we're
validating, that we're making
sure are really solid
and will make it in.
And there's others that we think
will probably always be
kind of a manual configuration
kind of option.
A good one of these is where
we defer JavaScript.
That's a complicated thing to
do and has generally amazing
effects on websites.
But it is something that you
want to hand-validate, and you
don't want to just
turn that on.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So I think this highlights kind
of a general point, which
is to say there is a core set of
filters that you should be
able to turn on or that will be
turned on once you install
mod_pagespeed, and your site
should just go faster.
But depending on your site,
you probably want to spend
some time going through the
available filters and just
seeing which ones may
apply to your site.
And you'll be able to get more
performance benefits out of
mod_pagespeed.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Right.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Very cool.
So I think we're going
to dive into the
details of some of these.
But I do want to touch on one
point, which is we do support
2.2 and 2.4 of Apache?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's
correct.
Apache 2.4 support came
out recently.
And that's in our 1.0
release as well.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Awesome.
And you mentioned that it's
just a couple of lines.
So we have, I guess, packages
for Debian and RPMs that you
can just install.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: We do, although
external developers
have generated packages for
openSUSE and even for Windows.
It's an open-source product.
We have a build process and
instructions for doing that.
And so people can put
up other packages.
FreeBSD is another
one has support.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So I can just build it
from source, right?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yes.
ILYA GRIGORIK: OK.
Cool.
And then one more
thing for 1.0.
I know that until recently, or
until we ship 1.0, there was
one release tree, if you
will, or one package.
And I think moving forward,
once we release 1.0, we'll
actually have two.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's right.
The current release package, if
you're using mod_pagespeed
today, you're on the
beta channel if you
installed from binaries.
And we're going to continue
to have that beta channel.
But the 1.0 release introduces
a new stable channel.
And the way that this will work
is that we will release
new features into beta.
And after we're really
comfortable and solid with
them, then we'll update
the stable channel.
And then when you update your
packages and your operating
system with yum update or
updating the Debian package
system, you'll upgrade
based on the
channel that you've selected.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Cool.
That makes sense.
All right.
So let's dive into
the guts of it.
But I think we touched
on this already.
I'll just mention it briefly.
The whole point, I guess, with
mod_pagespeed is to highlight
the things that you
don't need to do.
So instead of having to worry
about it do I need to have an
extra build process for
optimizing images or
concatenating my CSS or
JavaScript or all the rest,
all that is taken care
of by mod_pagespeed.
And in fact, that means that
I don't need to modify my
current workflow or my team's
workflow to take advantage of
all these optimizations.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's
exactly the point.
It's a drop-in solution for
performing best practices for
web clients.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So the clients,
or the visitors I should say,
would see the optimized
resources.
I still have my original
resources in my dev
environment.
And mod_pagespeed
does the rest.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Very cool.
So you mentioned this earlier.
We have over 100,000
mod_pagespeed installs today,
since you guys announced
the product.
And in fact, there is a number
of partners who have already
installed it as part of their
hosting infrastructure.
So for example, I know that in
DreamHost or Go Daddy, you can
actually go into your control
panel, click--
I think it's in these
settings.
I'm not sure exactly where
in the menu it is.
But I know there
is a check-box.
You say, please accelerate
my site.
And all of a sudden, the
site goes faster.
And what happens under the
hood is they enable
mod_pagespeed for your site.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's
exactly right.
Having that check-box to just
turn it on is even easier than
the three-step install process
that I mentioned earlier.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it's
like the Turbo button
back in the old days.
It's like make my site fast.
Why wouldn't you turn that on?
Very cool.
So let's dive into, I guess,
some of the guts.
Here's an example.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
So the best way to see
it in action, this
is a shopping website.
And we made a video comparing
a first view of that site on
Chrome with mod_pagespeed off
and with mod_pagespeed on.
And this is--
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this
is a side-by-side
recording of on and off.
Wow.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Correct.
So this video was made with
WebPagetest, which offers all
kinds of opportunities--
ILYA GRIGORIK: I'm going to play
that again just so you
guys can see it.
So the page loads
in 2.1 seconds.
And then the other one takes
about five seconds, if I
scroll back here.
And you can see that
the mod_pagespeed
one loads a lot faster.
Now, there could be many reasons
for this, right?
I'm guessing it's a combination
of filters that
come into effect to make
this difference.
But it's 200% faster,
or more, here.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
It's also important to note that
even though the rendering
takes 2.1 seconds, it's actually
pretty visible after
probably less than a second.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So if I just scrub back here.
So we have 1.8 seconds in, we
already have the page, whereas
the other one is blank.
So that's a dramatic
difference.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: So we can see
a little bit of why that
happened by going to
the next slide.
So those that have dabbled in
web performance have seen
these waterfall diagrams
that are available.
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's the
bread and butter.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: They're
available in Firebug and the
Chrome Developer Tools.
And these are from
WebPagetest.
Again, this is from Chrome.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this is
the same website, right?
We're just looking at the
waterfall charts.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
The same exact website.
On the left, the waterfall chart
is tall, which means
there's a lot of resources.
And it's wide.
There's a lot of
wide blue bars.
Those wide blue bars are big
images which don't need to be
nearly that big.
And so on the right, they
become a lot skinnier.
There's also a lot less bars.
So the two things that are most
visible in the waterfall
diagram, in terms of the effects
of mod_pagespeed
filters, are one, optimizing
images.
So there's actually three
ways in which
the images are optimized.
Number one, mod_pagespeed looks
at the context in which
images are displayed.
Very often, images are taken
from cameras at full
resolution and instantiated
into very small divs or
elements in HTML, 100
by 200 or something.
And there's way more pixels
being sent down to the browser
than the browser needs.
And this wastes bandwidth and
it wastes CPU time on the
browser resizing.
So it's much better to
resize on the server.
But who wants to do that?
Well, turn on mod_pagespeed and
it happens automatically.
The other thing is that the
images are typically at a much
higher quality ratio than you
need for an LCD display or a
retina display.
And it is pretty straightforward
to remove a
lot of the bytes of
that image without
reducing any visible quality.
And the third point is that
modern web browsers, including
Chrome and Opera, support a more
modern format of image
called WebP, which Google
released over a year ago,
which for the same quality can
get you about 30% less bytes.
And so this is not something
you would do manually.
But an automated tool can tune
the experience, tune the HTML
that's delivered and the images
that are delivered to
the browser in question.
So mod_pagespeed can take a JPEG
resource and transcode it
and deliver it as WebP to Chrome
and Opera, and to other
browsers deliver it as JPEG, so
that it works either way.
So between all of those, we
shrunk this site way down.
And actually, the waterfall
diagram, that blue line
represents the onload event.
What happens after the onload
event in this particular site
is third-party widgets that are
loading asynchronously,
which is great.
So the site was built with
that really well.
And so there's analytics
running.
There's buttons from different
third-party vendors that are
loading at that point.
But it doesn't block onloads,
so the user is fully
interactive at the time of that
blue line, which happens
way earlier than on
the other site.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it's really
interesting that just by kind
of blurring your eyes, we can
look at this waterfall and
just figure out what's happening
just on the shape,
without even looking
at the resources.
So you can say like, we
optimized the images.
We probably concatenated some
files, which is why it became
shorter, and a few
other things.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
I mean, mod_pagespeed is not
necessarily all that you would
ever want to do to make
your site fast.
It's now running in
two-point-something seconds.
So you could probably get it
down to one second, because
there's a lot of kind of
cascading effect here.
And there's not much
parallelism,
especially after onload.
And so diving deeper into the
waterfalls is something that
you might want to do if you
want that next level.
But kind of without any effort
at all you can get--
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
I'll take it.
Right.
2X just for turning on a flag.
I'll take it.
All right.
So now we will go under the
hood of this thing.
OK.
So we'll start with
a simple one.
So HTML Collapse.
This is an example filter, a
very simple one but it will be
a good introduction to
some of the more
interesting ones later.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
So this is kind of the simplest
possible filter that
you can have.
And this is actually a filter
that we have in
mod_pagespeed today.
It's a little bit more involved
than this in reality.
But this is essentially it.
You can, as every filter can,
register for interest in
various HTML events,
as it were.
And as the events stream through
the system, we can
say, hey, this one's
interested in
a Characters node.
That's all Collapse Whitespace
cares about.
And then it basically just wipes
out extra spaces that
it's pretty sure can't matter.
And cases where it would matter
is if it's in a pre
tag, and there's other
cases as well.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So it's not as simple
as it looks.
This is not like run a gsub
and remove all the spaces.
You're actually parsing
the HTML.
And you're saying, hey, this
is inside of a pre tag or a
script tag, so the white
space is significant.
But nonetheless, inside of your
regular HTML markup, you
can still compress the
extra white space.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
And this is a relatively
popular filter.
It's actually not
a core filter.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Interesting.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: And that's
because we are a little bit
conservative.
And it is quite possible for an
element to have its white
space become significant due to
a JavaScript event, which
is not something that
mod_pagespeed
currently looks at.
So this is a filter that's
pretty safe to do.
But we leave it up to users
to turn it on by default.
I've noticed a lot of users do
turn this on, because it's
mostly pretty safe.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
OK.
That makes sense.
So this is a more interesting
one, right?
So now we're talking combining
multiple CSS files.
So how does this work?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Right.
So the basic idea here is that
as HTML is streaming through
mod_pagespeed, we're
parsing tags.
We're saying, hey, here's
four link tags.
Let's collect all of those
together, collect the contents
of those, and collect the
names of the CSS files.
And we'll get into how that
happens in a few minutes.
But what it is that happens is
that those four link tags get
replaced with a single
link tag.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Which
is the one we see
on the bottom, right?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Which is the one
that we see on the bottom.
And it has the names of the
original CSS files separated
by plus signs, literally.
And then there is a .pagespeed
keyword, which is something
that we look for when
we are serving it.
ILYA GRIGORIK: It's
kind of a hint to
mod_pagespeed, if you will.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
And then there's a code
"cc," which actually
means Combine CSS.
And then there's a HASH.
And this HASH is
very important.
This HASH is the technology that
lets mod_pagespeed serve
any resource with a one-year
cache lifetime, because that
HASH is the MD5 sum of the
optimized resource.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it's the MD5
sum of the combined CSS files.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Right.
So it's kind of a signature
for this file.
Or you could think of it as
a version of this file.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So if I modify, let's say,
big.css, and I add extra white
space, and I save it, the MD5
sum would change, and you
would regenerate
this resource.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's correct
if we didn't minify that CSS
file and get rid of
that white space.
ILYA GRIGORIK: OK.
Right.
So white space is
a bad example.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: But if you
actually change the content of
the CSS file, then we would
have a different MD5 sum.
So we might have cached
this one for a year.
And you might think it's stale,
but it's OK because
we'll never reference
it again.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
OK.
And I guess maybe to backtrack a
little bit, and the reason I
guess we want to do this is
fetching multiple files
consumes maybe additional
TCP connections.
So by combining it all
together, we have one
resource, which you can
fetch down faster.
And hopefully that'll lead to
a faster render on the page.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
This is kind of the height
of that waterfall
chart that you see.
If your waterfall chart, for
example, doesn't fit on your
screen, you know that you
have some work to do.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
Yes.
That's a good rule of
thumb, in general.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: The other point
that I want to make is
that by providing long cache
lifetimes, you make all the
caches that are in the network
in between the server and the
client more effective.
You make the browser cache
more effective.
You make any caching done at the
ISP layer more effective.
And you make content delivery
networks more effective,
because the versions of the
assets that they store, they
know that they don't have to
check back with the origin to
revalidate for a year.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
OK.
Very interesting.
So let's take a look at
the monster diagram.
So maybe you can just walk us
through what happens when an
HTTP request comes up.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Sure.
So this is the view of what
happens in Apache.
Apache has a module
architecture, which allows
anybody to write their own
Apache module that can help
make some kind of transformation
to the content
or the networking.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Some examples
are, like, mod_deflate,
mod_security.
There's lots and lots
of these things.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Actually,
mod_deflate is a really good
example, because what that one
does is-- the most important
thing that you can do even
before you run mod_pagespeed
is make sure to always
compress your output.
And that is basically an output
filter that just looks
at the stream of bytes that are
coming through it and just
makes them smaller and adds the
header to say, by the way,
I gzipped it.
ILYA GRIGORIK: This is a little
bit of an aside, but
would you use mod_deflate
with mod_pagespeed?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Actually, if
you have mod_pagespeed, we
will turn on mod_deflate.
So they work together.
Mod_pagespeed would be less
effective if mod_deflate
wasn't there.
But they're complementary,
because mod_pagespeed doesn't
attempt to gzip assets itself.
It depends on mod_deflate
to do that.
But it does make them smaller
in the first place.
And image compression is
not really addressed by
mod_deflate as well.
So the way that an Apache module
works is that it can
install into the Apache kernel
an input filter, which takes
requests and mutates them in
some way that's particular to
the filter.
Content generators can look at
URLs and say, either I know
how to handle that one.
I'll take it over.
Nobody else needs to
worry about it.
Or, that one's not for me.
I decline it.
I'll pass it on to
the next one.
And they can install output
filters, which just get put
into the chain of the byte
stream as it goes through.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So here in this diagram, you
just have the PHP handler.
So if I have a .PHP file, it
would intercept that and say,
hey, that's for me.
I will generate the
byte stream.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
So mod_pagespeed puts a handler
in which looks at
those .pagespeed .resources.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it's like
a custom extension.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
And that's for handling
resources, for handling
images, CSS, and JavaScript.
For HTML, it installs an output
filter where it looks
at this stream of
bytes going by.
And whenever it finds HTML, it
parses it and tries to make
optimizations in it as
it goes through.
So if an HTML file comes into
Apache, what will typically
happen is it'll go through
the input filters.
The PageSpeed resource handler
will look at it.
But it won't do anything
with it,
because it's not a resource.
The PHP handler, if PHP was
handling those, would take the
URL and generate HTML out, which
would then be sent to
mod_pagespeed's output filter,
which would start looking at
HTML and deciding, based on the
tags and the characters
that are parsed, whether
it wants to mutate
those bytes or not.
An important thing that
mod_pagespeed tries to do is
never slow down the page.
So some of the things that
mod_pagespeed does are
actually compute-intensive
or rely on the network.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
That was actually going
to be my question.
It sounds like a lot of work.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: There is
definitely work going on.
So there's HTML parsing, but
streaming parsers go fast, so
that's not really a problem.
But when we have to go and
optimize an image-- well, we
have to fetch images, we have to
optimize images-- we'll do
that in the background,
typically, and also optimize
them in the background.
So we will only do the tag
replacement for images if we
already had that in cache.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Interesting.
So let's say I've just started
my web server.
Nobody has hit it.
And I make the first request, I
would still get the original
unoptimized resource them?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's right.
Probably for the most part,
your resources will come
through unoptimized,
but Collapse
Whitespace would work.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
OK.
So you would apply filters
that work really fast.
And then on the second hit, you
would actually serve me
the optimized content.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
That's a very good point.
OK.
So maybe one more quick note,
which is to say we talked
about PHP, but I think it's
important to note that one of
the strong or popular
applications for Apache is
that it can act as a proxy.
So if you have some other server
running somewhere--
that can be another app server,
maybe it's a Ruby app
server, Java, what have you--
and you're using mod_proxy,
this still applies, right,
because it's effectively
another handler?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's
correct.
It's easy to set up
mod_pagespeed as a reverse
proxy or actually as a forward
proxy as well.
And that way, it can optimize
content that's not necessarily
even generated within
the Apache server.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So if I have a
Java server running right now
serving my assets, I could
actually put Apache in front,
turn on mod_pagespeed, and maybe
inherit some of these
observations for free.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Right.
That would be a reverse
proxy application.
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's right.
Very cool.
So we talked a little
about images.
And images are a big deal
on the internet today.
Just prior to this, we were kind
of talking, and we said
that over 50% of all the
bandwidth on the internet is
video, which is moving
pictures.
But then the second-biggest
component is still images.
So you guys put a lot of work
into optimizing images, in
particular.
And you already covered some
examples, but this is kind of
an in-depth look at
what happens.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
This is kind of the life of an
image as it flies through
mod_pagespeed.
You're right.
A lot of the benefit of
mod_pagespeed, the real wins
in terms of bandwidth usage and
latency that mod_pagespeed
gets, at least in the core
filter set, on first view are
from making images smaller.
And so we put a lot of
effort into that.
And this is how it works
at a high level.
So we install a filter called
the image rewriting filter,
which scans for elements with
image tags, and it looks for
the source attribute.
And the way that it works, in
order to not slow down HTML
even on the first view, is it
looks in a metadata cache to
see if we've seen this resource
at this width and
height before.
So because we're optimizing
images for the element that
they're going to be drawn into,
those all go into the
key of the metadata cache,
if you will.
And so when that's a hit, if
we have a warm server, it
doesn't matter whether the
browser cache is warm or cold,
but if the server cache is warm,
then all we have to do
to deliver that optimized image
is swap out that source
attribute with the one that we
found in our metadata cache.
ILYA GRIGORIK: The optimized
version of the image.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
And so if it's a miss, though,
then we pretty much have to
give up on this round, because
we're not going to fetch a
large image and optimize it
on the fly it without
delaying the HTML.
So we spin up a machine that
runs in the background--
not a physical machine, but a
finite-state machine that runs
in the software--
and it goes off and
it does the fetch
of the image resource.
It runs the image optimization
algorithms.
And we discussed what
those were before.
So we can do transcoding.
We'll do resizing.
And we'll do recompression.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
And I'm guessing you guys also
do stuff like removing extra
metadata, which is
pretty popular in
like PNG images, right?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Sure.
That's actually--
in the core set, we'll remove
the metadata and resize, and
then it's an option
to recompress.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Actually, I'll
highlight the resize, because
I think this is very
important.
You mentioned it, but I think
it's still worth talking about
for a little bit.
So if I have an image--
say if I have an image tag that
says the width of this
image is 100 pixels and
the height is 100
pixels, so it's square--
but I can actually push a
larger image into it.
It can be 1,000 by 1,000, which
is actually not uncommon
on the internet.
Somebody takes a photo.
They resize it in
whatever editor.
They upload it.
And you're actually getting the
full-res image, which then
gets rescaled in the browser.
So just by providing the width
and height in the markup,
mod_pagespeed will be smart
enough to look at that and
say, yes, but the origin image
is much bigger, so let me
rescale that and serve
the proper version.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
I would go further to say not
only is it not uncommon, it's
quite common to take images
from your camera
and put them online.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this alone
saves me a lot of time,
because if I'm thinking
about--
if I have a lot of images,
you mentioned kind of the
newspaper use case
earlier, right?
Lots of images there.
I can just define the width and
height and push kind of
the resizing logic
to mod_pagespeed.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's
very cool.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: And so we do
this kind of gauntlet of image
optimizations.
And when it comes out the other
side, we have a new URL
with kind of the instructions
on how that got created and
coded into it.
So this image in this
example-- this is on
modpagespeed.com, which has
all of our examples.
On modpagespeed.com, you'll find
this Puzzle.jpg is the
origin image.
That's shown in green.
The width in which it was
displayed in our sample page
is 256 by 192.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So this is from the
HTML markup.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
It was a JPG file originally,
but we were
displaying it in Chrome.
And we took it and now we're
going to transcode it to WebP
so that it's delivered
more efficiently.
We also put into the URL the MD5
sum of this image file so
we can serve it for
a long time.
And even if I change Puzzle.jpg,
then it won't be a
problem with stale caches.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
It's kind of a similar
pattern to what we
saw with CSS earlier.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: OK.
And I guess the WebP one is
really interesting, because
this would get served-- you
mentioned because this was in
Chrome, you'd get WebP.
But If I visited the same
website in, let's say, Firefox
browser, which currently does
not, unfortunately, support
WebP, I would still get a JPG.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
So as a site owner, you can
make a decision, by using
mod_pagespeed, that you're going
to serve images in a
modern web format that is not
supported by all browsers, but
your site will still work
well on all browsers.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Very cool.
So that's not even something
that I could do with a build
step, right?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Correct.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yes.
Very nice.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: So I wanted to
dive into a little bit of what
the PageSpeed Optimization
Library is.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this is
the part that powers
modpagespeed.com, right?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Right.
So this is a server-independent
library
that does all of these
optimizations.
And the way that it gets hooked
up to-- and again, this
is completely open-source
software.
But the way that it gets hooked
into a server stack is
that whoever is doing that
supplies some mechanism to do
HTTP fetching and some mechanism
to do caching.
And in different environments,
there are different
technologies for accomplishing
these things.
ILYA GRIGORIK: These things
are implemented in Apache.
So Apache, I'm guessing, already
has an HTTP fetcher,
which you reuse, but the cache
is likely something that you
guys have implemented
yourself.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Sure.
Actually, the cache that we use
for mod_pagespeed is also
open sourced and would be
the default setting.
But typically, in a serving
environment that has some
maturity to it, there will be
some other caching solution
you'll want to use instead
of the one that
we have open sourced.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So in fact,
maybe could I even use
something-- like if I'm building
something with this
library, I could use
memcached, right?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yes.
Yes.
You're kind of forcing
me to tip my hand.
So a feature that we will be
releasing soon but is not yet
in 1.0 is support of memcached,
which is an
important feature for
scaling up websites.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
Nice.
OK.
So if I have a custom server, I
could actually take this and
build my own mod_pagespeed
variant.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
Yeah.
There's API documentation
on the web in
the developers' site.
And we would be happy to support
actively anybody
interested in porting this
to a new platform.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
And we'll mention this later,
but you guys do have an active
Google Group where people can
come in and discuss, propose
new filters, file bugs, all
that kind of stuff.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
There's actually a variety
of support forums.
There's the Google Groups.
There's the issues list.
People seem to be
fairly active on
Stack Overflow as well.
We try to be responsive.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
I see a lot of questions
there.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: We try to
be responsive to that.
But we track everything in our
issues list, which is all
accessed off of code.google.com.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
OK.
Perfect.
So I wanted to highlight a few
kind of tips, configuration
tricks, and a few
other things.
We looked at the guts.
We talked about kind of
high-level things.
But one question that I get
quite commonly with
mod_pagespeed is like,
OK, great.
So I grabbed this,
installed it.
I ran these three commands.
Now it's on.
What if it doesn't work, or
I'm scared, or how can I
experiment with mod_pagespeed?
And there's a couple
of ways to do that.
First of all, because we have
this additional module
installed, you can actually
configure through a couple of
different ways.
So you can use query parameters
that will be
intercepted by mod_pagespeed.
So for example in this rewrite
CSS example, we have
ModPagespeed=on, which basically
says turn on
mod_pagespeed for this
request only.
So you can have it disabled,
but I'm going
to enable it here.
And by the way, enable
this specific filter.
So if I want to experiment with
some non-core filter, I
can just pass this in, see what
happens, kind of test the
waters, and then decide if I
want to make that the default
for my configuration or not.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
It's kind of a way to
interactively rapidly iterate
on your site without having to
restart Apache or anything.
ILYA GRIGORIK: I think it's one
of my favorite features.
I love just being able to
quickly get feedback on, how
is this going to look?
One alternative to that is to
actually send HTTP headers.
So if you have some sort of a
client or server solution that
you want to test with,
that's another way.
And then the last one is-- we
actually mentioned this-- the
mod_proxy forward proxy
example, where you can
actually say, please fetch me
this other site and run it
through PageSpeed and
show me what will
happen when we do that.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
This is a very good way if
you're considering the option
of using mod_pagespeed on your
site, but you're nervous about
like installing it and rolling
out to your users without kind
of looking at it first--
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
Let's install it on 1,000
servers and see what happens.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: --you can
install it on one server local
to your system, which is running
your origin content.
It's running as a proxy.
And then you can look at your
site through mod_pagespeed by
setting a browser proxy.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
That's a very handy tool.
And in fact, all three of these
are documented really
well on the mod_pagespeed
site.
So I have a link down here.
But if you guys search on your
favorite search engine for
mod_pagespeed and experiment,
you'll find instructions for
how to set up the mod_proxy,
which is really handy.
I wanted to highlight this,
which is we mentioned already
that there is a lot of
different filters.
And we do have good
documentation.
And there's a couple different
resources.
So one that you mentioned, which
is modpagespeed.com,
where we actually list
all the filters.
And we actually also
provide the demos.
So it's usually kind of a simple
file which illustrates
what the filter does.
So if you guys want to take a
look at that, that's a very
good place.
And another one is, once again,
the configuration, or
config filters, page on our
developers.google.com site,
where we actually explain
what each one does.
And we also highlight which
ones are in the
core set and not.
And another thing I'll mention
is that by default, when you
enable mod_pagespeed,
as Josh said, you
have your core filters.
But you can actually
say, don't worry
about the core filters.
I'm going to hand-tune all
the filters myself.
So you can customize it
completely for your site.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
By turning on the core filters,
what you're doing is
you're kind of letting us make
the decision as we move the
software and advance it of what
we think is safe for most
sites, and you'll take that.
If you want to have total
control, and when you upgrade
you'll decide which filters you
want to enable for the new
release, then you can put it in
pass-through mode and then
add the filters that you want.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So that's a good point.
So I should probably, unless
I have a specific reason to
avoid core filters, I could
leave that on because maybe in
the subsequent release you guys
have added another filter
or improved another filter such
that now it's considered
safe, and that would just be
automatically included during
an upgrade.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
I'll give you an example.
I believe in the current
release, we have a filter
called Flatten CSS Imports.
One of the biggest anti-patterns
for performance
in CSS files is to
use at-import.
But it's incredibly convenient
to do it.
As a designer, that's
what you want.
You want to be able to
structure your code.
You want modular code.
So that's a good thing.
It's bad how it's delivered.
Mod_pagespeed with the Flatten
CSS Imports filter will
flatten those all out so you get
the best performance when
you deliver it, but you don't
have to maintain that.
That was something that
we built into the
product some time ago.
But we wanted to do a lot of
testing on it to make sure it
was rock solid.
That's being promoted into the
core filters in the next
release after 1.0.
And so if you have
core filters then
you just get that.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Interesting OK.
That's good to know.
So we also touched on
some configuration.
But one of the really nice
things about Apache is that
you can configure it in a
million different ways.
So there's your Apache config,
where you can specify your
virtual hosts.
So mod_pagespeed can be
configured at a v-host level.
So an example, down here we're
saying mod_pagespeed is on for
this example site, and
pass-through is actually the
command that tells us, don't
include the core filters.
I'll hand-tune the filters
that I want.
So we're just enabling these, I
guess, five filters for this
example site.
But I can also be much
more granular.
I can use the htaccess file.
So for example, I
have my v-host.
I have my example file.
But in my slash, I don't know,
assets I want to have a
different set of filters, I
could actually drop in an
htaccess file with another
configuration.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Right.
And there's yet another twist,
which is you can use a
directory scope in the
configuration file.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So I could literally have
different filters running on
different subsections
of my website.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
Actually, the implementation
of just how the options get
configured is itself a pretty
big topic within the
mod_pagespeed codebase, because
you can configure my
request headers, by query
parameters, by virtual host,
by director scope, by virtual
host, and at the root.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
But I think it highlights
the fact that our users
have asked for that.
So they are using all of
these mechanisms to
customize their sites.
So we needed to have it.
And it allows you a lot
of flexibility,
which is very nice.
And experiments.
So I think this is something
that you
guys added just recently.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's right.
We've been traditionally using
WebPagetest, which is an
amazing tool for doing
detailed analysis.
That's how we produced the
video and the waterfall
diagrams that we saw earlier.
But WebPagetest will allow you
to run your tests from a set
of servers that are running in
some corner of the world.
There's ones in Singapore,
in Dublin, in
Virginia, and so on.
But what you really want to do
at some point after you deploy
is see what experience your
actual users are having.
And so what this does is it
injects some performance
measurement, using Google
Analytics, right into the web
pages and allows you to bucket
users into experiment groups.
And you can say, for example,
first of all you would
establish what Google Analytics
ID you want to
report the data to.
And then you can say, well, I'm
going to send a third of
my users into kind of a control
bucket which doesn't
have any optimizations in it.
mod_pagespeed is running, but it
isn't doing anything except
injecting the Analytics
experiment.
The second one we can say,
let's just have the image
compression and nothing else.
And the third one, let's have
the default settings.
Or there's a whole set of
options that you can do to
customize your experiments.
Then you can let this run
for a day, a week.
Depending on the experiments
you might leave a small
control group just to see how
it's doing, and go back to log
into Google Analytics and see
how users for each bucket are
faring in terms of the latency
that they're seeing
on their web pages.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this
is really cool.
So what you've described there
is the difference being
synthetic testing and real
user measurement, which I
think is what you're referring
to when you're saying Google
Analytics, right?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yes.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And we actually
had an episode with Justin
Cutroni from Google Analytics
where we talked about
navigation timing and why
it's so important.
And the point that Justin always
loves to make is that
it's great that the developers
want to optimize the site.
They always want to
optimize the site.
But how does it affect
my bottom line?
Like the business metrics,
the dollars as he put it.
So this will actually
tell you.
So we have three buckets here.
And if I have in my Google
Analytics some conversion
metrics-- that could be a
purchase, that could be a
registration, even time on
site or bounce rate--
now I could measure against
that and say,
well, you know what?
Users that get a faster
experience
are staying for longer.
Maybe they're converting
for more.
And that makes for a very
compelling case to the rest of
the team to say, this is why
we should invest into more
performance optimization.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Awesome.
I love the business use case.
It's not just like speed
for speed's sake.
Although speed for speed's sake
is also good, because it
makes the web faster.
So this example, this is
actually a very common
question that we see, which is
many people have already
applied some optimizations
to their site.
So a good example of that
is something like domain
sharding, where the problem is
that modern browsers allow up
to six connections per host.
So if you're hosting a lot of
images on your domain, you may
get blocked as you're trying to
download a lot of images.
So the general best practice for
that is to say, well, host
it on different subdomains.
And then that will allow the
browser to open multiple
connections--
more than six, I should say.
But that creates a little
bit of complexity for
mod_pagespeed.
This is where you need to
kind of hand-tune your
configuration.
So can you explain what's
happening here?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Sure.
So the challenge is
that you want to--
well, there's a couple
challenges.
So if somebody has hand-sharded
their domains or,
in many cases, just done a
simple best practice of moving
their resources to cookie-less
domains, which is all good,
the first thing that you
have to do if you want
mod_pagespeed to be effective
is you have to let us know
what those domains are, because
mod_pagespeed doesn't
know what the domain
mapping is.
So we have pagespeed.com
settings to tell us.
So the first thing you have
to tell us is what are the
domains that are basically
equivalent on your site.
And so if you have, like,
static.example.com, your HTML
is coming on www.example.com,
you have to authorize, at
least with ModPagespeedDomain,
static.example.com.
And if you've done
hand-sharding, you may have to
authorize more than one of those
and tell us that they
are essentially equivalent by
mapping them to kind of a
canonical name.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So if I'm running example.com,
and I'm serving images from
example.com, then mod_pagespeed
would say, yes,
I know that I'm hosting this.
Hence, I can optimize
this asset.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: But if I'm
hosting on a cdn.example.com,
that could be anywhere, or it
could be a third-party asset.
So mod_pagespeed won't touch
that by default.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Right.
If for example you're serving
an image on Flickr or
something, Flickr is not yet
running mod_pagespeed.
And so if you just rewrite the
URL the way we did with the
.pagespeed [INAUDIBLE]
and it's on Flickr, then it
just won't work, because
Flickr won't be able to
decode that name.
So we wouldn't necessarily
authorize that.
But if you have images on your
site that you want to put onto
a CDN that knows how to reach
back to your origin, then you
can do a domain mapping to say,
I want to take the images
that are on example.com and put
them on cdn.example.com.
Now when mod_pagespeed rewrites
that URL, when it
optimizes the image or the CSS
file, et cetera, it will
rewrite the domain to
go onto the CDN.
This is, I think, kind of a
development feature which
allows you, for example,
to develop locally
and turn that off.
But then when you're ready to
actually push resources to the
CDN, you can turn that on.
This also allows you
to apply sharding.
So by establishing the shards,
if you want to, for example,
shard two ways, then you can use
the command that we gave
here, ModPagespeedShardDomain
example.com to
example1, and example2.
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's
the bottom one here.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: And then
mod_pagespeed will kind of
randomly disperse the resources
to those two domains
so that you can have more
parallel connections.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So this is
definitely a more advanced use
case where that's going
to reach deeper into
mod_pagespeed and also think
about how does this work in
the context of me using a CDN.
But that in itself is actually
an important point.
It is CDN-friendly.
So you can make it work with
your CDN provider and help
your CDN serve optimized
assets.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
And this is something that
I think it's useful to
experiment with.
One of the things that you
probably don't want to do is
try to hand-shard your resources
in your HTML file,
because the best practice
is to shard domains,
but exactly to what?
I've seen the right answer be
four, the right answer be two,
the right answer can sometimes
just be one.
And so all the effort you do to
hacking your HTML to edit
the domains really is kind of
counter to the notion that you
want to experiment with it.
And you can experiment very
easily by just iterating over
your pagespeed.conf file and
looking at WebPagetest.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yes.
That certainly makes
it a lot easier.
Yeah.
So we talked about the
forward proxy.
But I recently came across a
blog post, I think it was
Frank Denis that wrote this
really awesome blog post that
kind of blew me away, because
what he did was he used
mod_pagespeed as a forwarding
proxy for his phone.
And the basic observation was
that when you're on your
mobile device, you probably
don't have a Wi-Fi connection
most of the time.
You're in 3G.
If you're lucky, you're
in 4G, what have you.
And you're downloading these
massive websites.
So instead of using
mod_pagespeed to accelerate
your site, why not use
the rest of the web
as you fetch it?
So in this diagram here,
I have my phone.
We're sending a request through
this forward proxy,
which is running
mod_pagespeed.
Mod_pagespeed requests the
actual site that I requested.
I get this fat response back
with all kinds of unoptimized
images, et cetera.
Mod_pagespeed crunches all
of that and sends me the
optimized assets, which
I thought was
really, really clever.
So he did this with
his iPhone.
And he observed that for the
sites that he tested it on, he
got much faster renders
and much fewer bytes.
And in fact, he shared
some examples.
And we'll take a look
at those later.
But these are the actual
filters that he used.
So he shared those.
And some examples that I wanted
to highlight was first,
he enabled core filters.
So that's kind of by default.
But I think he just
wanted to have it
in there to be explicit.
He said, I'm going to rewrite
images, convert JPGs to WebP--
so he knows that he's accessing
this on Chrome on
iOS when he's using that--
convert PNG to JPG.
And in fact, this is an
important one that you
mentioned earlier, when I'm on
a mobile device, I have a
small screen.
I probably don't want 100%
fidelity of all the pixels.
I'm OK with the 75%
compression ratio.
And that gives me a
lot of savings,
byte savings for images.
So this is kind of an
interesting example.
And he also did a couple of
aggressive filters, which say
defer all iframes until after
onload and other things, just
to accelerate his browsing.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yes.
And pointing out, in particular,
defer JavaScript
has a huge impact on the
speed of websites.
It's something that you want
to look at the results
of when you do it.
It was aggressive to put it into
a forward proxy, but he
was extremely happy
having done it.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
Yeah.
And these are some examples.
So of course, this is not
representative of the entire
web, but he kind of
highlighted a few.
So for example, this over-blog
URL, it went from 400
kilobytes to 271, which
is pretty significant.
Going from 39 seconds of onloads
to 2 seconds is a big
improvement.
And not only that, but you can
see that because he was
combining resources, it
went from 34 to 21.
So the mobile browser had
to make fewer requests.
All of those things are a win.
And he got a better
mobile experience.
Now this next one just kind of
completely blew me away,
because I didn't believe it.
But it serves as
a good example.
Cooking With Frank.
So this is a blog,
lots of pictures.
And guess what?
The unoptimized version
is 3.15 megs.
With compression, it comes
out to be 10 times
smaller, 340 kilobytes.
So when I'm on my mobile data
plan, I probably want the 340
kilobyte version.
It'll load much faster.
Instead of making 85 requests,
it made 28 requests.
So this is a dramatic
difference.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
We're still learning exactly
what works really well on what
kind of mobile device and
what kind of connection.
But it seems likely that having
a lot less requests
will benefit mobile even more
than it will benefit desktop.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
So this, in general, seems like
a very interesting area
to explore for mod_pagespeed,
like I want this on my phone.
So just a quick recap.
We've covered a lot
of stuff here.
So we talked about the
upcoming 1.0 release.
It's an open-source
Apache module.
It works with 2.2 and 2.4.
Kind of the pitch, if you
will, is just-in-time
performance optimization
for your website.
And it's already very widely
deployed across the web.
So we feel it's 1.0 ready.
It's 1.0 ready by Google
standards, which
is perpetual beta.
So that says a lot.
But one question I do have for
you is, what's after 1.0?
Are we done?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: I feel
like we're at the
beginning of this process.
We've definitely discovered
that there is some meat to
chew on here.
There's a lot more
that we can do.
SPDY is an obvious topic.
The rules change when you're
working with SPDY.
Combining becomes less
important, because you can
multiplex multiple resources
over the same connection.
Inlining becomes
less important.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Same
reason, right?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: In the release
that is coming after the 1.0
release, we'll start seeing
some of the deeper SPDY
integration.
So Google also has a module
called mod_spdy, which we work
pretty well with.
And look for more
in that space.
I would say the big wins that
we have right now, images;
extending cache lifetime, which
is something that really
benefits repeat viewers to
things like news sites;
deferring JavaScript.
There's kind of other big areas
where we're more aware
of the networking
characteristics of the page
and we're optimizing.
I feel like we're relatively
early in our understanding.
We've found a lot of
good things to do.
But when we find good things to
do, it usually uncovers 10
more that we don't have
time to do yet.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
So I think that's very
representative of the web
performance community
in general.
I think we're still finding a
lot of interesting edge cases.
And the browsers are only
getting smarter.
We're only getting more and
more assets on the web.
So in fact, we know that the web
pages are growing, both in
size and number of requests.
So it sounds like there's
a lot of work to do.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: There's
an astounding
amount of work to do.
But I think that we've come to
a point now where we have a
stake in the ground where we
have demonstrable benefit.
We have adoption.
And we'd like to grow it.
And we're ready to take
off from here.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I'm glad that
you guys are doing it,
because that makes my life
a little bit easier.
I can install this and inherit
all of the work that you've
put into this.
So I think for the last
slide here, we've
covered some of these.
But I want to highlight these,
because I get these questions
quite frequently on Stack
Overflow, through email, and
through other means.
So I kind of bucketed them.
We already talked about
mod_deflate, mod_expires.
So those work together
with mod_pagespeed.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's right.
In fact, mod_pagespeed
turns mod_deflate on.
And it's kind of dependent on
mod_expires, because we have
to know how often to pull
the origin resource.
And you definitely want to
put an expires header.
You want to use that.
Tell us how often to check back
to see if your resource
has updated.
Actually, I just want to point
out one other thing.
Mod_pagespeed can also look
directly at the file system,
in which case it can just stat
the file to see if it's
changed, which is a little bit
more efficient if your files
are right there on the same
server, as opposed to being
generated by PHP or pulled
from somewhere else.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Actually,
that's a good point.
That's another config flag
that you can find in our
documentation.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's
correct.
So that's mod_pagespeed
load from file.
And I think that if the files
are there on your disk, just
get mod_pagespeed to look
at them directly.
But if they're not and we have
to do a fetch to get them,
then you definitely want to use
mod_expires to tell us how
often to do that fetch.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
OK.
For the CDN , I think we've
covered a little bit.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
We covered it.
CDNs are driven by the
cachability of resources we
make things cachable
for a year.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Which also,
I think, answers the next
question which is, if you're
using a CDN-- or maybe if
you're not using a CDN, rather,
but you are using
another cache in front, maybe a
Squid, a Varnish, what have
you, maybe Nginx, those should
still work, right?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
ILYA GRIGORIK: They'd just
be more efficient.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Exactly.
They'll just have to pull
the origin less often.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
OK.
Perfect.
So we talked about or
we mentioned the
mod_pagespeed cache.
So mod_pagespeed has
its own cache.
We talked about the
upcoming memcache.
But as a developer, do I need
to worry about that?
So if I have my assets--
and who manages that?
If I update my asset, do I need
to worry about flushing
the cache, et cetera?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: So mod_pagespeed
comes
pre-configured to use the
file system as a cache.
And that works reasonably
well.
As you scale up websites, you
have to think a little bit.
We set the default cache, I
think, at 100 megabytes.
Is that enough for
your assets?
Or do you want to
make that grow?
ILYA GRIGORIK: So it's something
you can probably
tweak in the configuration.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: That's another
configuration parameter.
How often we go and garbage
collect that
cache is another question.
So when you change your assets,
you don't have to
manually purge the cache.
Mod_pagespeed will just
do it automatically.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And that was
actually that file name kind
of scheme that we looked
at earlier, right?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yeah.
Well, the files on the cache
have recognizable names.
But they're not exactly
that scheme.
But the hierarchy of your URL
space for your assets is
reflected in the cache.
So you can kind of poke around
the cache and see
what we have in there.
And you can just delete it.
They're just files.
ILYA GRIGORIK: But it sounds
like generally speaking, I
shouldn't be touching them.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: But you don't
really need to touch it.
You can just configure how big
you want it to be and how
often you think we should
go and purge it.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Perfect.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: And upcoming,
you'll be able to say, well,
instead of storing the files on
the disk, I want to store
them in memcache.
And here are the host
and port numbers
of my memcache instances.
And then you can share that
cache among multiple servers
so that you can scale up your
website a little bit better.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Yeah.
That's very cool.
So we actually talked about
affecting or not affecting the
page load time when the
cache is empty.
So that was that if we don't
have the image resource
optimized, we will just serve
the original image.
But on the next hit, you will
get the optimized resource.
So as you said, the last thing
that mod_pagespeed wants to do
is to make your site slower.
That would be the
anti-pattern.
So that should never happen.
But I'm guessing all
of this work does
consume some resources.
So what should we expect?
If I install this on my
server is there kind
of an average number?
Does it really vary based on
the site, because it seems
like it would, right?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Sure.
A very image-rich site that
installs mod_pagespeed for the
first time will go through
a period where we'll use
resources on the server to
optimize the images.
There will be a bounded
amount of resources.
This is actually another config
parameter that you can
set, because we don't know
exactly how many CPUs you have
or anything.
But by default, we will do, I
believe, eight concurrent
image optimizations maximum
per physical machine.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
So it's like background workers
optimizing these images.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: And
that's across all
of the Apache processes.
And so it doesn't just fan out
arbitrarily until it kills
your machine.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
That would be an anti-pattern.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Yes.
That would be another
anti-pattern for serving your
resources efficiently.
But what will happen is if you
have a page full of images,
and the first time somebody
goes to them, we'll start
spinning up the optimization
of those, once those are in
cache, that'll settle
back down.
So there will be typically
be a few minutes--
it would vary on the site--
of where all these images get
optimized, put into the cache,
and then you're good to go.
If the cache is too small,
then it might be ongoing.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So the most part,
if your website doesn't
change dramatically every couple
of minutes, chances are
your visitors will be just
hitting the cache.
And you would only see this
extra work being done when you
have new assets or, for whatever
reason, that asset
got evicted from the cache.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Right.
ILYA GRIGORIK: And that's where
you may want to go back
and configure or check, is
your cache being used up?
Maybe you should increase
the size or
something to that extent.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: This is probably
also a good time to
point out that mod_pagespeed
offers some visibility into
what it's doing, because it
has a statistics page.
So on the local server, you
can go to mod_pagespeed
statistics, which by default
is accessible
only from local host.
But you can configure
that too.
And then you'll see how many
image rewrites are going on.
You'll see a variety of
statistics, which kind of give
you a way to put your finger on
the pulse of mod_pagespeed.
ILYA GRIGORIK: So I'm guessing
if I'm using some monitoring
system, I could probably get
the variables out of there,
shove it into Ganglia or some
other system, and track all
that performance
there as well.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: It's
very scrape-able.
And in fact, I think very soon
after mod_pagespeed was
released people started to say,
well, I've hooked this up
to this visualization system,
and here's what it's doing.
ILYA GRIGORIK: That's the first
thing that I would look
for as well.
That makes perfect sense.
So shifting gears a little bit,
we didn't specifically
talk about mobile, with the
exception, I guess, of the
forward proxy.
But is there anything in
particular that we need to be
aware about for mobile
and mod_pagespeed?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Mod_pagespeed,
this is actually one of the
areas where I think we can do
a lot more in the future.
But we're already providing a
substantial benefit, making
things smaller and
less requests.
It's all good.
ILYA GRIGORIK: It's images.
We saw that, right?
JOSHUA MARANTZ: It's all good.
What Frank Denis did was
he cranked the quality
level down to 75.
Typically, we would recommend
if you want to do this for
desktop, we would say 85
is a very safe number.
But for mobile, you might want
to crank it down further.
I can't think of anything that
mod_pagespeed does that would
be undesirable for mobile.
I think it's all good.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Smaller
resources, fewer requests, all
of those things are prime
candidates for improving
mobile performance.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: The
only question, is
there more we can do?
And the answer is absolutely.
Stay tuned.
ILYA GRIGORIK: Right.
I think that's a good note
to kind of end this on.
I'll just mention that we do
have a lot of online resources
about mod_pagespeed, if we
didn't answer your question.
So good places to start
are modpagespeed.com.
I think there's actually links
to the Google Group, the issue
list, and demos there.
So that's a great place to
kind of kick off your
exploration.
We do have a Google Group where
you can ask questions.
And of course, you can also just
reach out to myself or
Josh, and we will be happy
to answer any questions.
So thank you, guys.
JOSHUA MARANTZ: Thanks.